heywhat someone named Samuel leaves and
this week I'm gonna be answering your
property investment questions I did this
every week and you know what I really
really enjoy it I've been investing in
property for over a decade and I've
built up quite a large property
portfolio I've also trained thousands of
people in property and written a
best-selling property book and this week
while I answer property questions what I
want you to do is I want you to ask me
your property questions and next week
I'm gonna answer your property
investment questions
so let's see what they've got this week
but first please give me a massive
favour to match the light burn subscribe
to the channel turn the notification
belt on and get commenting your property
investment questions below let's see
what we've got Ben Grove he says hi son
you'll hope you don't mind me replying
to a few of the questions of course not
that's what I'm here for
I just turned 19 have a bite to let on a
counsel scheme emergency accommodation
I'm firstly respect that you're a
teenager and you ever buy to let
property that's really massive so well
done forty thousand pound raring to go I
intend to use the BRR strategy but if
you want to film a series of financial
freedom challenge flipping properties
I'd love to be considered have a great
day I bet that's amazing honestly I
don't know if there was a question in
there per se but I'd be very willing to
do something so hit me up on social
media no promises but I I just can't
wait to do more challenges like that so
good job
hope to meet you in person real soon
keep up the good work Benji Fox says hi
Samuel my question is what did you do
different to everybody else in the
industry to become a millionaire whilst
others still or not how did you build up
your money then just a really good
question I guess it's the millionaire's
question or I became a millionaire I
started out investing in property and I
wanted to invest so I bought a property
refinanced it the same day put it in my
stepdads name because I was too young to
get mortgage and I slowly started using
strategies like lease option agreement
so I was managing properties to try and
get my foot in the door and that's how I
became financially free how I became a
millionaire believe it or not was
actually through deal sourcing because
once I become financially free building
my own property portfolios either then
thought okay I want to go buy more
houses but
got money and one of the ways that I
wanted to raise money I thought well if
I maybe find some good deals and pass
them on to investors charge a fee I can
use the fee to build my own portfolio
and I became really good at that
and I've sold hundreds of property deals
charging minimum of two thousand pounds
sometimes up to seven thousand pounds
and that is actually how I became a
millionaire when I was 25 doing that
combined with my own property
investments and then I snowboard my
portfolio refinance to continue building
it and that's how it happened I think if
you want to be a millionaire and you've
got to work addictiveness ly hard you've
got to invest and you've also got a mate
moment you've got to be an entrepreneur
and you've also got to be invested
together and when you row the tools hard
it can happen but it's not necessarily
for everybody however I do believe that
everybody can become financially free
meaning that they replace their job with
a property passive income and that's
really what I'm about teachers so hope
that helps great question
what's next Tyrone Saxton he says I'm
not love Tyrone Tyrone you're on like
every week and it's great to see you
doing so many property deals HMOs and
different things I hope to meet in
person one day Torrance's for my 4 bed
HMO that I already have an ode in North
Hampton respect I purchased the HMO with
planning permission already granted that
runs out in March 2021 I have permission
for the kitchen to be made bigger and
for a fifth bedroom do you suggest like
go ahead with the extension or put the
money towards a deposit for a second
house what's your opinion so that I know
what to do Tyrone Saxton Tyrone great
question initial it all comes down to
return on investment so if you're going
to put a fifth bedroom in the house and
you're going to exercise the planning
permission to extend the kitchen how
much additional income is that going to
give you and it might be that the the
extension I don't know how much it costs
let's say it's twenty five thousand
pounds but that's going to give you a
lot extra income because everyone's
going to like the like the kitchen and
they're going to pay more rent you've
got a nice fifth bedroom which is going
to be extra so it might be a good thing
to do however my gut feeling would
probably be that you'd be better off to
put that to one another property because
then you've got two houses you've got
two lots of rents you've got to lots of
capital appreciations
probably would be better I wouldn't
freak out about the Planning Commission
because even if it laps
you're probably going to be able to
renew it anyway the fact that they gave
that you want it's not like you're
asking to do something crazy but my
advice would be do the figures on both
and see what's giving you the best
return on investment and then make a
decision good luck you should document
it vlog it I'd love to watch ok um MW
2002 Fitness hey good to see that you're
into fitness great stuff hey man do you
know when your crash courses are opening
again as I still have a ticket from when
I purchase one of your books great stuff
I'm really itching to you know what I
love doing YouTube absolutely love it
more than YouTube I love running
training live training programs and not
being able to do that for these last few
months has been weird and I'm itching to
get back to it so I promise as long as
the government allows it as soon as they
allow it I'm gonna go back to running
events again so I don't know what it'll
be maybe September time we'll see but
I'm itching just as you are and I'll see
you there Alex Ives hi Samuel do you
need c3 permissions for went to s a no
you do not need planning permission or C
to change it to c3 unless the council
requires it but normally to run a
property serviced accommodation you
don't need any planning permission there
are exceptions such as in Greater London
you do so my suggestion would be to
contact the council and ask them the
question and if they don't know and you
what you gonna say you're just going to
say for short stay let's do you need
planning permission do I need to c3 and
if they're not sure you can always apply
to get pre-planning but I doubt you
would be and I doubt that they're gonna
know if you really counts they're gonna
know so it depends on where you are but
probably not and to be honest if you do
rent to si I wouldn't even bother
working in an area where you need
planning permission to do a service to
accommodations because you don't even
own it so you don't want to change the
planning on a house and you don't even
own I hope that helps good job I look
forward to seeing your results
Tommy 77073 says and what happens when
house prices drop and tenants can't pay
bills due to lack of jobs that's a
pretty pessimistic thing to say well
first let's hope that
doesn't happen house prices dropping
listen I'll address the two points
because you said and what happens when
house prices drop and tenants can't pay
bills due to lack of jobs if house
prices drop it's not really that bad
because if you own a property just
giving you rent unless the plan is to
buy it to sell it you just continue
getting the rent as normal so it doesn't
actually matter if it goes down property
prices go up they go down they go up
they go down and it doesn't really
matter unless just selling and then it's
a pain yes my advice would be to not
worry about where it's going to go up or
down worry about the cash flow of the
property because the definition of an
asset and your properties should be an
asset is something that puts money in
your back pocket every month so if it
drops in price for a bit it doesn't
matter as long as you continue to get
the rents next point there is what about
if tenants can't pay bills due to lack
of jobs I don't think that's going to
happen and here's why due to lack of
jobs if people do if there is big
unemployment and people lose jobs
statistically and historically actually
whence go up and the reason is is
because if people are struggling
financially because of unemployment and
a job lack of jobs then they haven't got
that much money so instead of buying
because they can't afford to buy they
rent because you've got to live
somewhere so actually if there is a lack
of jobs rents will probably go up
especially rents that aren't like
luxurious mansions like HMOs if you're
renting that HMOs room rents go up a lot
in a recession so III think that you
just need to be probably a little bit
more optimistic and make sure you're
buying the right kind of properties and
not relying on iconic going up high fast
but in some areas property prices aren't
going to rise anyway so there's a whole
big discussion I've looked at chat to
you and I hope you found that answer
helpful Robert Thomas thank you for
doing this I have two questions in
regards to buying a first property would
you recommend using a bridging loan for
its deposit and as a first-time buyer
would a mortgage to be easier to attain
I apologize if the questions are dumb
I'm very new to learning about property
investing currently reading your books -
great stuff Robert I'm really glad that
you're educating yourself or on YouTube
you read in the books
I'd be really careful about using a
bridging loan on your first property
especially if you don't quite understand
how it works and you're new to this
bridging those are really expensive and
they should be to bridge the gap between
the purchase and the mortgage so a
bridging loan is something that you're
probably only going to get for like
three six twelve months max the only
time to get a bridging loan would be if
you're buying the property cash and
you're going to use a bridging meant to
buy it with the view to refinance it
once you've lifted the value of the
property and before you even do that you
want to speak to a broker or make sure
that you are eligible to refinance the
property as well so I'd probably say
keep educating yourself speak to a
mortgage broker and if you've got any
more questions comment them below guys
if you enjoyed the video smash the like
button also don't forget I've want to
answer your questions too so get
commenting if you comment on my videos
every single week that's great if you've
never commented on a video ever before
maybe you should break the trend and
comment right now dan Greenwood Samuel
new to your channel but loving the
content just bought my first property
under market value are brilliant stuff
down at 159 thousand pounds spent 14
thousand pounds on renovations and got
help from trades people in the family 5
months later is now laid at 195
fantastic not a huge profit but giving
I've no prior experience I'm happy keep
up the great content you've helped
inspire me to make this my career going
forwards that's so called Dan honestly
that's amazing so you point four one
five nine spent 14 which musing total
you spend on seven three so you've
bought if one seven three one nine five
that's good that's really good that's
like a 22,000
anyone the match isn't great right now
for some reason but fantastic job I'm
really really pleased if you want any
help with it let me know keep commenting
keep me posted on getting on and that's
excellent amazing gamer amazing gamer
you're the guy that always comments
first and likes first so respect he says
how I send me what would you do if
you're a deal sorcerer and I found an
amazing property lead but the estate
agent tells you to view it but you can't
leave due to this pandemic amazing game
I would view it I know I know that some
people are really spooked out by Corona
still and they're scared to leave the
house personally I mean if if the agents
are open if you're worried just
social distance you know wear a mask if
you need to but I would personally just
go and view the house because people are
viewing houses right now and you don't
want to miss the opportunities that are
being snapped up good luck
let me know how you get on amazing gamer
Thomas Thomas says hi Samuel thanks for
the free content keep up the great work
thank you you too my friend I set up a
limited company last September and
pursued an investor to come on board
currently on my 10th property deal
amazing which has been largely off the
back of your videos that's really cool
man thank you for sharing that a mixture
of buy refurbished refinance and
standard white solare on average
percentage-wise how much value will will
adding an extra bedroom to a property
create first of a massive massive
respect world and tenth property you
know what the fat think you guys
commenting on the channel now are so
different - two or three years ago two
or three years ago it was all like oh
what's a BRR what's the HMO now people
are saying I'm on my 10th deal I'm
almost financially free I've got this
third hey chime at like honestly um it's
really really satisfying for me so I
know I'm even feeling like emotional
right now saying this which is weird for
a Kunis and a video I'd forgotten your
question and everything good job man
it's really really good to say okay on
average percentage-wise how much value
will adding an extra bedroom create it
depends on the house so okay hmm pens on
the house adding an extra bedroom I
would probably suggest speaking to an
estate agent in the area because if it's
a HMO it's like a four-bed hey Chema and
you want to turn it to a fifth bed hey
Cho that's gonna add quite a bit of
extra value because you're gonna
increase the rent a lot whereas if it is
like a two-bed house and you turn to a
three bed house but there's not much
price difference maybe go on Rightmove
and see the difference between to bed
and three beds and speak to estate
agents because it really depends on area
and stuff so a but honestly respect hope
to catch up has Matt hi Sam can you use
money from a remortgage as a deposit on
a buy to let mortgage yes you can if you
refinance a house
use that money to do whatever you want
and I would suggest that you do use it
for that purpose okay one more
some say Altima haha you're right about
what you said about me Samuel I remember
I made a prediction from your question
you commented for the very first time I
made a prediction on your whole life
story and I was right there it's really
good
yes I have had a well-paid job which I
hope to give it up to a concentrated I
should concentrate on my property
business I think now I am financially
free respect for what you teach that's
just awesome you guys need to apply to
come on the YouTube channel I can
interview you listen if you've become
financially free or if you even got like
a great story honestly there's nothing
that makes me feel better
and more fulfilled and there's nothing I
prefer doing apart from running events
then sitting with people in my house and
interviewing them on my youtube channel
on Windows on a Wednesday so listen guys
you clearly killing it I'm really glad
go on winners on a Wednesday comm share
your story with me and I'd love to
interview you and chat with you and
inspire more people because you know
what success breeds success which means
my success as I've shared that with you
has helped you and then as you share it
will help other people and I really
believe that together we can make the
world a better place by educating people
about finances the schools have failed
to do it the schools do I loved I loved
the schools but as far as finances are
concerned they failed they don't teach
you about anything about money anything
about property investments or passive
income so they failed to do it so I
believe that we as a generation need to
start teaching finances need to start
creating opportunities for people and
leveling the playing field I really
believe that the rich are getting richer
the poor are getting poorer and unless
the people are educated that's just
going to keep happening more and more
more
so appreciate you watching my videos get
down to Windows on a Wednesday continue
putting in the work graph take the
knowledge
graft subscribe to the channel smash the
lifeline and I'll look for to seeing you
on the next video peace out
[Music]